we've talked a little bit about
ribonucleotides but in this video I want
to talk about deoxyribonucleotides and I
want to talk specifically about deoxy 5
male 8 synthesis so how is it that
deoxyribonucleotides are made well the
only difference between a ribonucleotide
and deoxyribonucleotide is the two
primal age group or a 2 Prime hydrogen
group right so if we want to change a
ribonucleotide into a
deoxyribonucleotide we would do that by
reducing the two prime OAH group of a
RIE bow nucleoside diphosphate because
the enzyme excellent specifically to
just a hydrogen using NADPH so NADPH you
learned before is involved in reductive
biosynthesis right so this is a
reduction reaction where we're making a
deoxyribonucleotide so which enzyme
catalyzes this process three enzyme that
catalyzes this process is ribonucleotide
reductase which makes sense we're taking
the ribonucleotide of or reducing it
specifically arrive on nucleoside
diphosphate it's also known as RNR it's
also known as ribonucleoside diphosphate
reductase it's just a more specific name
because it acts on a ribonucleoside
diphosphate so I'll actually include
that here so we have a ribonucleoside
that phosphate right which could be UDP
CDP GDP or ADP now to look like this
right I have a nitrogenous base ribose
sugar with the O weights group with the
two prime carbon and then two phosphate
groups because the diphosphate we want
to turn this into is we want to turn it
into a deoxy nucleoside diphosphate
right so we D UDP or dctp dgtp d adp and
the only difference between this and
this is the two prime carbon here we
have an OS group so it's a
ribonucleoside diphosphate here we have
just the age so it's a deoxynucleotide
diphosphate so again this reaction is
catalyzed by RN r right this
ribonucleotide reductase and it uses
NADPH to provide the electrons for that
reductive process right here we have
oxygens you
we just have a hydrogen's we're reducing
the number of bonds to oxygen that's a
that's a reduction reaction so NADPH is
oxidized to nad p+ okay notice that none
of these here
I didn't note thymine right I mean was
not discussed above in this reaction so
how is the oxy that middle late made
well if you recall climbing nucleotides
exist only in DNA right not RNA so
that's important now how is the oxy that
mid-late made well if we have D UMP
right the oxy your diene mana 5/8 all we
have to do is methylate it its
methylated to make d TMP what does that
mean what with the heck what's going on
here right so uracil looks like this
right Simon looks like this what is the
only difference the only difference is
what's going on here right Diamond has a
methyl group so if we want to make a
thymine nucleotide or or specifically a
deoxy nucleotide always to do is take
the your the uracil and add a methyl
group that's exactly what happens we
have a deoxy your ad mono phosphate and
we add the methyl group to make dtmp so
that's this reaction here so this
reaction notice again the ulna mat
highlight it one more time here this is
the only difference between these two we
have a D UMP deoxy your 18 5 prime mono
phosphate and detoxify Medine 5 prime
mono phosphate so now the only
difference is between these two is that
this doesn't have a methyl group and
this one does so we're creating here
this thymine or this timing nucleotide
deoxynucleotide specifically and the
enzyme that catalyzes this step is
called by mid-late synthase
so all we need to do is add that carbon
right add that methyl group so what
provides it there's this molecule called
n 5 and 10 methylene tetrahydrofolate
and it is turned into seven eight
dihydrofolate in this reaction and the
reason why is because what does this
thing do what is what is this process
what's happening here well this n 5 n
time methylene tetrahydrofolate is
providing that carbon group that methyl
group so it provides the methyl group ok
now this reaction is actually really
really important especially because it
applies to cancer chemotherapy so if you
check out the next video you can see how
this reaction specifically is important
when thinking about cancer or at least a
form of cancer chemotherapy so I hope
that was helpful one last thing I am a
tutor if you live in Southern California
feel free to contact me via email at
boof University at gmail.com and see the
description below for more details
thanks for watching